[Music]
in 1745 a mysterious man was arrested in
london and charged with spying he called
himself the count of saint germain and
for almost 200 years the count of saint
germain was present at every significant
political event in the world and always
looked the same age some say he walked
the earth during the time of christ
some say he walks the earth still
this is his story
[Music]
1745 was a difficult time in england the
jacobites propped up by the french
monarchy had seized edinburgh that
summer england was capturing imprisoning
and executing spies everywhere the man
who called himself the count of saint
germain was arrested in a coffee shop
under suspicion of espionage and was
taken in for questioning the count's
captors quickly learned that he was
fluent in every european language and
other languages from around the world
still he wouldn't tell them where he was
from or what his name was boris walpole
the prime minister's son wrote that
saint germain could sing compose and
play the violin so well that one would
have thought he was a famous musician
though he appeared about 45 years old
nobody had seen him before while in
custody he gave details about historical
events that only an eyewitness would
know saint germain's jailers found him
extremely odd and during this time of
rebellion foreigners in england were
imprisoned simply for being foreign yet
somehow without giving his real name age
or place of birth the count of saint
germain was set free word quickly got
around about this strange man who could
speak every language composed music and
a spoke of history as if he lived it
when the prince of wales heard the
stories he wanted to know more so he
sent for the count but it didn't matter
the count of saint germain was gone
[Music]
when western soldiers returned from the
crusades they brought with them legends
from the east and one of those was the
story of cartophilus also known as the
wandering jew as jesus dragged his cross
on the way to cavalry he stopped to
catch his breath cartophilas stepped
into the street and told jesus to stop
resting and move along jesus said to
cartophilus i shall go and i will rest
but you shall not rest until i return
cartophilus didn't know what jesus meant
by this but as the years passed
cartophilus's friends and family grew
old and died though he never aged he was
destined to walk the earth immortal
until christ's return now this was taken
to be nothing more than a story until
1228 when an armenian bishop spoke of
having dinner with a strange man who
spoke of history as if he was there the
man called himself partophilus for
centuries after cartophilus was seen in
the middle east then europe it seemed as
if the wandering jew was wandering west
then one day a mysterious stranger
arrived in paris he dressed simply but
elegantly in all black he wore diamonds
from head to toe he had rings on every
finger and even had diamond buckles on
his shoes he appeared to be about 45
years old and he called himself the
count of saint germain
when the count of saint germain arrived
in paris he appeared out of nowhere but
he made an instant impression on the
social class he was obviously a man of
significant means but nobody knew where
he came from or where he got his money
he became the must-have guest at any
dinner party he was a talented pianist a
singer and he could play the violin so
beautifully that people were moved to
tears and he was a brilliant
conversationalist who would dazzle
anyone no matter where they were from he
was fluent in french english spanish
italian russian dutch german and
portuguese and native speakers couldn't
detect an accent the count could also
speak conversational polish chinese
arabic ancient greek latin and sanskrit
he had immense knowledge about
everything science art philosophy
politics but where he really excelled
history he would give accounts of the
lives of henry viii nero cleopatra and
famous historical figures and when asked
how he could know so much about people
that had been dead for hundreds of years
the count would simply smile and say i
was there he even claimed to have met
jesus christ personally
right this would make the count well
over a thousand years old which brought
challenges from parisian skeptics but
whenever another historian would try to
stump the count on obscure details the
count always knew the answers in
addition to being a talented musician
artist and historian he was also a
gifted alchemist he claimed he
discovered the secret of the
philosopher's stone a process that can
change base metals into gold he said he
had discovered the elixir for life which
is how he accounted for his youthful
appearance
saint germain even impressed the famous
philosopher voltaire one of the keenest
minds at the time and voltaire said of
saint germain he is the man who knows
everything and never dies now i admit
the story of the count of saint germain
sounds fantastic and supernatural but
everything we know about him comes from
eyewitness accounts but the only way to
really know if the count was telling the
truth about his age is to find someone
who knew him in the past and could
identify him in the present turns out
there was such a person
one evening the count of st germain was
mingling with the elites in paris and
countess fongiorgi recognized him from
when he was in venice in 1710. about 50
years earlier the countess asked
saint-germain if he perhaps had a father
or grandfather who was in venice at the
time he said no madam it was i who had
the honor of paying you court the
countess couldn't believe it she said
the man she had met 50 years ago wasn't
more than 45 years old and here was
saint germain who looked the same age in
fact she thought he might have even
looked a few years younger he said madam
i am very old and he went on to give her
details of their meeting and she was
stunned and said that must make you over
100 years old the count smiled and said
this is not impossible soon after that
word reached king louis who found the
story as entertaining but didn't give it
much thought but when the king learned
that the count had a process for
removing the flaws from gems and turning
lead into gold the king said bring this
man to me at once the count of saint
germain accepted the king's invitation
and immediately left for the palace at
versailles
[Music]
when the count of saint germain arrived
at the royal palace in versailles he was
an instant sensation casanova himself
wrote about their first meeting he said
the count of st germain was a scholar
linguist musician and chemist and as a
conversationalist was unequaled and
casanova noted the count never ate he
would sip mineral water and occasionally
drink herbal tea but he never saw him
consume food of any kind he's a vampire
well that's one of the theories the cow
had traveled to the palace with an
assortment of equipment and substances
that he used for his alchemy experiments
he created makeup and special face wash
for the ladies of the court which they
swore made them look years younger and
he told the king of a process he
invented for colors and dyes that would
increase the value of french fabrics but
the king wasn't interested in fabric he
wanted to know about the count's
abilities with precious stones the count
said he had just spent five years with
the shah of persia who taught him an
ancient and closely guarded technique
for removing flaws from diamonds and
even creating larger diamonds by melting
smaller ones together now the king was
skeptical of this claim to which the
count replied your majesty i have
witnessed christ turn water into wine
diamonds are a mere trifle the king
proposed a test
king louis had a diamond that was valued
at six thousand francs but without its
flaw it would be worth ten thousand
francs or more the count said he could
remove the flaw in a month a month later
he returned with the diamond flawless
king louie's jeweler examined it and
valued the stone at 9 600 francs the
king was impressed and set the count up
with his own laboratory right there in
the palace the count of saint gerain
became a fixture at versailles for the
next couple of years the count worked
all day in his private lab and spent all
night dazzling the king's guests but one
day the king went to pay the count to
visit and once again the count of saint
germain was gone
[Music]
throughout the 18th century the count of
saint germain would pop up all over the
world he was seen by sir robert clive in
india he was at the hague trying to
broker peace between prussia and austria
anton mesmer namesake of the word
mesmerize received the count when mesmer
was a young physicist in germany he said
saint germain possessed a vast
understanding of the workings of the
human mind and had been directly
responsible for teaching mesmer the art
of hypnosis some say this was how the
count was able to talk his way out of
the english prison jedi mind trick yep
i'm not the count you're looking for
you're not the count we're looking for
move along move along move along move
along
[Music]
the count was in russia and helped bring
catherine the great to the throne he was
in holland attempting to end the seven
years war he met up with casanova again
in the north of france where he
according to casanova's own memoirs
turned a pocket coin into gold in all of
these accounts saint germain appears 45
years old after the death of louis xv
the count of saint germain suddenly
reappeared at versailles and he warned
king louis xvi and maria antoinette of
the coming revolution he said a giant
conspiracy would disrupt the entire
nation and the king was in danger now
the royal couple dismissed him but in
her memoirs maria twinette wrote that
she wished she had taken the count more
seriously in the summer of 1776 the
second continental congress gathered in
philadelphia to sign the declaration of
independence but the meeting wasn't
going smoothly some delegates feared war
with england the most powerful country
on the planet then just as talks were
breaking down
a voice thundered from the back of the
room and gave a rousing speech about
courage commitment and freedom inspired
by these words the delegates immediately
rushed forward john hancock had barely
finished signing when another took up
his quill america would be free when the
men looked up to thank this gentleman he
was gone his name was never recorded and
though the room was locked and guarded
he was able to enter and leave without
anyone seeing him all that's known is
that he was a man of average height and
build dressed all in black who appeared
about 45 years old in 1779 saint germain
befriended prince charles of germany and
spent the next five years as a guest in
the prince's castle then on february 27
1784 the count of saint germain died of
pneumonia he was laid to rest at a local
church and his funeral service was
attended by many of the people whose
lives the count had affected no that's
it but
in 1785 a year after his death the count
of saint germain had returned
[Music]
in 1785 a year after the count of saint
germain supposedly died he was seen once
again with anton mesmer in germany later
that year the french freemasons had
chosen as their representative the count
of saint germain he was seen at the
taking of the bastille in 1789 and at
the execution of marie antoinette almost
40 years later the count was seen in
paris several times by mademoiselle
d'attamar who'd known him from years
before she wrote in her diary that she
was amazed that every time she saw him
he still looked 45 years old in 1870
emperor napoleon iii was so fascinated
by the count that he created a special
commission to investigate him a year
later a mysterious fire destroyed all
the records they gathered
it is in 1877 saint germain was seen
again at a freemason lodge in venice in
1896 the ocifists annie bessant and
madame blavatsky said the count had been
in contact with them he claimed to be of
an immortal race who come from a
civilization hidden beneath the
himalayas
a theosophy is a religion that claims
there's an ancient and secretive
brotherhood of spiritual beings known as
the masters and these masters are said
to have great wisdom and supernatural
powers in 1914 during world war one the
count was captured by two bavarian
soldiers they said he spoke many
languages and wouldn't tell them where
he was from but he did say the war would
end in 1918. the soldiers thought he was
crazy but they let the man ramble the
count said that a tyrant from the lower
classes would wear an ancient symbol and
lead germany into another global war in
1939 and that germany would be defeated
in six years but not before committing
unspeakable acts of violence the
soldiers were so unsettled by the
strange man that they let him go i'm not
the camp you're looking for right
in 1930 guy ballard met the count of
saint germain on mount shasta in
california and ballard claims saint
germain was one of several ascended
masters like jesus christ and ballard
formed an entire religion called the i
am activity movement around saint
germain's teachings at one point the i
am religion had over a million members
and it still exists today there are many
other sightings of the count throughout
history but these are the most
well-known and best documented so that
leads us to two big questions first was
the count of saint germain a real person
well he most definitely was there's no
debate about it but was he immortal
well we'll address that in part two wait
what you're not gonna tell us now nope
that's a bunch of i have a
reason for doing this in part two we'll
see if we can separate the myths from
the facts and figure out who the count
of saint germain really was i still say
bullsh
thanks for hanging out with me today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files if you had fun or
learned anything do me a favor and like
subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps the channel and until part
two be safe be kind and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you